afternoon welcome to the
simons institute uh my name is peter
bartlett i'm the associate director here
and uh thanks for joining us for this
richard m carp distinguished lecture
this is a series we established to
celebrate the role of of dick carp in um
theoretical computer science he was the
founding director of the institute
it's a series that features visionary
leaders in that field and in neighboring
areas
it's geared towards a broad scientific
audience
and we're grateful for the many
contributors to the richard m park fund
who made this series possible
so i'm delighted to welcome our speaker
today wilfred gungo
wilfred is professor of mathematics at
ucla
he's made important contributions in
optimal transport calculus of variations
and partial partial differential
equations
and we're thrilled to have him in
berkeley this semester for the program
on geometric methods in optimization
sampling
wilfred's a fellow of the american
mathematical society he was a
chancellor's professor at uc berkeley in
the math department
in 2018 and 19. he's been an eisenbud
chair at msri he serves on the
scientific advisory boards of the
pacific institute for the mathematical
sciences and of the msri and he's been
an nsf program director
he's also been very active in mentoring
roles most recently in co-founding with
jalani nelson and todd coleman the david
blackwell summer research institute
this is a program for undergrad students
that aims to increase the number of
students in particular african-americans
in top-level mathematics
and his talk today is entitled on some
optimization problems involving a large
number of matrices please join me in
welcoming wilfred gungler
thank you it is a great pleasure and uh
and
honor to talk here and uh i would like
to thank the organizer for inviting me
so when i hear
peter comment
very positive comment
at some point i start wondering who he
was talking about
okay so my talk is based on a trying to
work with uh
david jekyll
is my colleague
siri
it is possible that i miss right he's
his
last name i'm sorry
about that
and this is about
optimal transportation
non-commutative
optimal transportation so
uh i want to warn you
that
if you try to make a parallel between
what i am i'll be saying and what you
know about the optimal mass
transportation
you are going to confuse your yourself
so
yes so
on one hand you have a
classical
mechanics
which corresponds to optimal
mass transport
and on the other hand you have a quantum
mechanic
where things are non-competitive
and here
you have a particle in motion
and there you have a state
quantum systems are represented by state
in a hilbert space
i will
list some example
very soon
and
in the case of classical mechanic
you have random variables
when you assume that
you are given
a set
and the probability measure
so this is an atomic
measure space
and all the atomic measure space are the
same there is an isomorphic between
atomic measure spaces and so the one you
choose doesn't matter you can choose the
same one to describe
your phenomena
and
here
you have a
the random variable will be replaced by
a bonded operator
on a hilbert space
so there is a no reference
hilbert space
which will work to describe everything
so it is not like a here
and the analog of
l2
omega
rd
p
this hilbert speed h
will be replaced by
algebra
so if you look at
a description
i am making a here
and you try to map it here
there is not such an analogy
except in special cases
when i am dealing with operator with
commute
we can write an explicit relation
between this and that but when the
operator don't commute there is no
search
relation
so
let me start with
an example
of a quantum system
so my hilbert space h
will be
and the set of bonded operator
linear bonded operator h i am going to
identify it with a set of
n by n
matrices with a complex number entries
and i am going to assume that i am given
s1
sd
in
and c
and i will only assume that they are
safe i don't even if sometimes i may
forget that that i will already be
working with self-suffrageta
operator
now here you see
the operator and n
this d is never going to change this is
what is going to change this is what is
going to go to plus infinity
so the analogy here is uh i'm working
with
with a measure which are average of n
direct masses and when i let n go to
infinity i get
all the measure and
the
the measure are supported by rd so these
are the correspond to data d
so you can make the following
observation remark
this remark is met to say that
when i use the tracer letter it is not
something i choose by accident i don't
have many choices
if you look for
now which are from
m and c
into c
which are linear
and satisfy the property
tau
of m is
m bar
of one
is one
power of a b
is powerful
power of a
star a
is greater than zero with equality
there are not many
uh tau satisfying this property there is
only one it is given by tau of a
is
1 over 10
this sum
so it is the normalized trace
apply to a
therefore once i choose my filbert space
and i stood the set of bounded operator
i have no choice if i am looking for
function which satisfy all this property
i have no choice but
working with that specific
function
now
when you have
a random variable
if i give you this random variable
from the mass transport point of view
you don't need to know everything about
the random variable what you need to
know is
the push forward
of
the probability
measure when you are doing math
transportation that is
all that matter
and
a way to know the push forward of this
is equivalent to when i integrate over
omega f
s of omega
p d omega
if i know this for every f which is
continuous then i know my mu
but by the way stress approximation
theorem
if i know this for every polynomial then
i know it for every continuous function
so a measure is completely determined by
its moment
similarly when i am given
this
quantum system
s one
s n
tau n
and
when i'm giving this a quantum system i
am going to assume that
not a full information is available to
me what is available to me is the moment
of this map so what i mean is
i only know the trace
of
s i 1
to the power
k 1
s i l to the power
k l
for i1
il
between
1
and
d
and
for k
j
speakers
so rephrasing
i am saying that
to each
polynomial non-commutative polynomial of
the variable
i know the map
lambda s
of p
which is defined by the trace
of
p of s
and i am going to call
s1
sd
these are the non-commutative
random variables
and
lambda s
will be a non-commutative law
so we want to understand a little bit
what information have we
collected
here
so let us take a
vacation to
let us get take the case d call to one
s
is in m n
c
this is the set of one
over n
sum j from one to n
delta
lambda j
yes
where
lambda j
x
are the eigenvalues
so from what you see here
the dimension may disappear
because
if i take a
twice a dimension
and i sum up
it is possible that
i repeat it is possible that i use a
matrix
where the eigenvalues are repeated and
so when i look at
what i get i don't see the dimension all
i see is a measure
so the point i am trying to make is a
two quantum system which come from
two different dimensions may still be
compared so i want to compare quantum
system
even if they don't have the same
dimension
another case
of
which is
remarkable
is
assume
that
the commutator
of s i s j
are zero for every
i g
then you can define a measure mu s
defined by the integral
over rd
alpha mu
dx
f of x
is the trace n
of
f
of s for every f
polynomial
and again since i can approximate every
continuous function by polynomial in the
commutative case i am defining a measure
here
and
one can write a correspondence between
the
set i can write a correspondence between
reset
of lambda s
such that
s are commuting and
the set of probability measure
or no rd
so
this is we with uh
i am hiding something here
since my s have uh
uh
are bounded operator then the the
measure will be supported by uh the ball
of radius whose radius is given by the
operator so it will not be the set of
probability measure it will be the set
of probability measure with compact
support
so
here is
what i want to do
i am given two
quantum system
and i want to say how dissimilar they
are so i want to find the criteria to
decide
what i mean by them being dissimilar
and
what was proposed
by
bian and bruce kolesko
they propose a metric
on a set
so you can make the following
observation
remark
if
lambda
is either
from the s
or on that c
which satisfy
the following property
lambda of 1
equal to 1
lambda of cube
is lambda of qp
lambda
of
p star p
is greater
than equal to zero
and uh if i set
set r
to be the maximum
of
the operator norm of sj
j
from 1
to b
you can check that
lambda of s
i one
s i k
is less than
r to the power k for every
i want
ik
and when lambda satisfies that property
i write
the following notation lambda is the
sigma d r d for the dimension and the r
to say what is the support what will
correspond to the support of my measure
and
sigma d
will be the union
r greater than 0
so
definition
is a metric which is defined on that set
so
letter
from the notes
london one
being a sigma
dr
so if they are here for r large enough
it means that
being sigma dr
and define
pi
of lambda naught lambda 1
to be the set of tau
in sigma 2 d
with the following property
tau
of p
tensor product identity
is lambda naught of p
and the tau of identity tensor product q
is lambda 1 of q
and this must be true for every p
which is in c
s one
s d
and for every q
which is in c
s
d plus one
plus
yes
[Music]
then the distance
squared
between
lambda knots
of that one
is by definition
we have female over tau
in pi
lambda not lambda 1
the sum j from 1
to d
and the tau
of
x
j
minus
let me write it this way
x j
minus s j plus d
you know respect to tau square
where by definition the norm of a tau
is
tau of a star
and you can check that this is a
metric
and they have the following
theorem
call this one
one
is a minimum
s1
sr
d
t one
c d
r in m
and c
r self adjoint
and the commute
sj
sk
0
cg
then the distance well let's go distance
between lambda s
and lambda t
is the versus 10 distance
so this is one of the rare cases where
you connect with a sustained distance
maybe i should not see the workers you
connect the vessel stand distance to the
non-commutative distance but there are
other cases where for instance you are
not working with large matrices and you
impose some
density condition on this life matrices
and you pass through the limit you can
show that
such a quality holder even if the
matrices don't commute so when you look
at this
what is
amazing is how short and simple the
proof are so let me give you an idea of
the proof
commit
so the first one
you check that pi
lambda naught lambda 1
is a compact set
of a point wise convergence
so the functional to minimize
is convex
in fact linear
lower semi-continuous
for the topology
and this concludes the fact that you
have
a minimizer
now for the second part
if you are commuting
you have
a relation
between
the trace and
the measure mu s so whenever
you take
an optimal tau
you can construct explicitly the
optimal
measure in the vasa style metric and
vice versa so based on this formula you
can go from
one set to another and so the second
part of the proof is
also very simple
so this is a a
this is a special case
of
what uh biennial voice called school did
i done that because i was trying to
postpone as long as possible the
introduction of full newman
algebra
because
i have a colleague
who we were writing a joint report
and when i wrote the phoneme and algebra
he asked me to take that off the report
okay so
i have an additional multiplication we
all know what an algebra is it is close
on the addition it is close on the
multiplication
so a star algebra here the star will be
the arjun to an operator i i associate
the adjoint of the operator and
so a sister algebra is an algebra which
is closer under
this operation plus
some condition on the norm which i am
not going to
write here so
let's let me see that
definition
for neumann algebra
is his sister algebra
content
in
bh
for hilbert h
so let me call it a phone number algebra
w
and you impose that
search that
w
is closed
on the
weak operator topology
and
one
belongs to w so one is the identity
mapper here
and of course uh
the set of matrices
is
a sister
algebra
so now
i can replace
in this definition
i cannot consider
lambda
from
so i want to define
a threshold
argument
so i am supposed to say a separable
threshold for human algebra beta here i
will be working only with
phoneme and algebra which are separable
and i'm just going to use
this terminology
so a tau
is a threshold
if
the pre-gl
a
if a star
the predial of a
is separable
now is
in the prejud
and satisfy the following property
uh
is
greater than or equal to zero
and the quality
and only
equal to zero and
i am going to use the notation
and you can check that this really give
you a norm and in fact you have an inner
product which you can guess
what it is
so
this theorem
is
you too
so they proved that
the distance
between lambda naught
and lambda 1
if
the distance between them
can be obtained
by minimizing
the
traditional fundamental algebra a
tau
x one
so x y
the
norm of x minus y
theta num square
subject to the constraint that
s1
sub d
y1
and so
you will probably
wonder why should i go from such a
simple formula to
this complicated formula
so think about uh
studying on a hamilton jacobi a question
on
this set
so you don't have any nice geometry
structure
now there is a well understood study of
hamilton there could be a question on
hilbert space
so if i can convert everything i have on
this space to the hillbill space
if i can prove existence and unique
uniqueness of solution
up to my half million there could be a
question on field birthdays i can
translate the resulter
on this non-flat space and uh
prove a resistance or solution so this
way of thinking has been successful in
the versatile space in the versailles
time space
when you want to serve
some equation like a the master equation
the way it has been handled so far is to
exploit what what we know about
uniqueness comparison principle of sorry
you don't have comparison principle for
the master equation but you have it for
hamilton there could be a question on
the non-local hamilton there could be a
question on the
last system space so
to prove uniqueness you express the
comparison principle on hilbert space
and then you'd conclude you have
compatible principle on reverse system
space for the master equation
you use the differential structure you
have on hilbert space
you prove uniqueness of solution it is
not a comparison principle result but
you use the fact that you understand
well what a gradient mean what the
hessian mean on the hilbert space and
you convert that to the verse system
space
so
although
i don't think they have this motivation
in mind
uh such a a result is very useful to go
from a flat space from flat spaces to
places which are not flat yes
i don't see where they land
yes
so you are going to impose that they
satisfy
that property
second question
like how how is important that h is
final dimensional or finite dimensional
words just for the example
just for example h is not a finite
dimension and i am going to convince you
that
you cannot even consider finite
dimensional i mean in general you start
in a finite dimensional space and you go
to infinite dimension i'm going to
convince you in a few minutes
can you also do similarly mark when you
are in a finite dimension or how do you
so does it goes exactly the same if
you're adding finite dimension don't
need to
so whether or not
so everything i am doing is true for any
arbitrary filter space whether it is
finite dimension or infinity dimension
was that your question yes no what i was
wondering is like more the definition of
the couplings
yes if these goals like uh exactly the
same way
because this this part doesn't see the
dimension
right this part i am working
on the set of non-commutative polynomial
ah because we also have boundary
operators okay yes
thank you
so if you are calculus couples of
variation personnel like me and you see
this minimization problem your past will
be minimizing sequence you want to prove
compactness and the proof resistance of
a minimizer and probably 10 years later
you are still trying to find out if you
can prove compactness and you will not
be able to
but some figure
something uh
very amazing
happen
so in the classical case
if i give you any probability measure
you can say it comes from a random
variable
and here the same is true
if i give you
any tau
if i give you any
lambda
or tau you can say that it comes from a
foreign algebra so
this uh
variational problem there is something
called
the
gel phone
i mark
sugar
construction
which says
the following
given
any lambda
which is
in sigma dr
there exists
iteration
fundamental algebra
s1
sd
which are self adjoint
search that
lambda
equal to
lambda s
so
you can show that every time i give you
an a tau sy you can construct
this is not a
good idea let us call this ba ba if
every time i give you a bar here you can
construct an element here
and this
dnc construction tell you that
conversely when you are given any tau
here you can say that they come from a
full neumann algebra so the fact that
you can go this way tell you that this
infirma is bigger than that one and this
construct tell you that
when i find my information here i can
construct a fundamental algebra and show
that my infimum is achieved
now
here is
something one of the
first results we got
for any n
greater than 11
if you set a d
to the n square
and you choose
arbitrary d
integer
we can find
um
we can find a s one
such that
call this a 2.
if a
is the optimal
if a tau
is optimal is the optimal in two
the dimension
and so you cannot say that when you
start in a certain dimension you stay
there your dimension can go as high as
possible
now we have the following result
there is something which is called
the cone embeddable problem so the
current variable problem roughly
speaking in some particular case
tell you that
if i have any lambda
in sigma dr
can i write it as a limit
of lambda n
where these are produced by a finite
dimensional communicative law
so
an answer
to
cone embeddable
problem a negative answer was announced
it is not published yet it is still
on the archive and
our theorem
will be if
the non-negative
answer
to the cone
by the one
your problem
is confirmed
we can take
therefore you can choose the two finite
uh system and the optimal one has to be
of
every dimension
so it is written
there is a written rule somewhere
in
the bible
of the calculus of variation
saying that
if you have a optimal transport there
must be a venomous bruni formulation
so
let me
define the analog of a gradient very
easy to define
so if i give you
if i give you p
a polynomial
of
the
variable
and i ask you to write a p of
x
plus epsilon
w
you are going to write that it is p of x
plus epsilon
something of order
one w and so on
so if i ask you to write the trace
we are going to write that
this is a twist
and uh remember that the trace if i do
a1
a k
it is cyclical the stress of ak
a1
ak minus 1 and so on so
the w which up here i can always
switch them so that
they appear at the end
and
this can be written
epsilon
twice
of an explicit operator which anybody
can write
multiplied by w
plus low
of epsilon and
this is this operator is called
the cyclical
the cyclic
derivative
so
given a path
if
t goes to lambda t
is an absolutely continuous path
so an absolutely continued path on the
metric space is
the distance
there exists
beta in l2
0t
such that the distance
between
lambda s
lambda c lambda s
from that c
is less than the integral from s to t
beta of star d tau for every
s and t
okay so if you have such a path
which satisfy this regularity property
you can
define
the hilbert space h
lambda t
you can define it to take the closure i
am going to take up the center of
polynomial
i am going to caution
by
lambda t
p
star p
equal to zero because if i don't
quotient with lambda
t will correspond to a semi norm but if
i quotient it will correspond to a norm
and i'm going to close this with respect
to lambda
and so the theorem
is
if lambda 0
that one
in sigma
then
distance
between lambda zero
from that one square
is then frame
the integral from zero to
one
the integral over lambda and v
lambda c
square dt
subject to the condition that lambda
zero is lambda naught
and that one
and
we satisfy
the continuity equation
d over dt
lambda c of p
equal to
lambda t
dp
dt
in the sense of distribution
for every p
polynomial
i think
i am going to start here
all right 15 minutes
thanks very much questions
okay
obviously so how does this relate to
kind of the description uh by uh carolyn
and mass of uh
uh
also we have animal brainier in the
spaces of operations as well
yes so
curling and mass
mass are transporting
one operator to another one
however
they
constructed
a metric
which is a specific so they wanted to
study
some
specific focal point equation
so they constructed in a metric
such that
we with respect to that matrix
the uh focal plant equation is a
gradient flow for that metric
now
uh these are not
comparable because uh
for instance here i am i am telling you
that in some situation i can say that uh
when thing commutes
then this is the vassa's time business
classical business and distance but uh
the mascara of brunier
uh also i have a paper with tanaban
china and the tree phone in this case
this
you
don't relate the data to the
classical verses and distance so these
are different completely different
metrics so the four groups
constructed four different metrics
second question is like um
is there a notion of typical
monotonicity
so
for the
for the first question
this in fact is uh
one of my motivation
i want to
look at the game
where
the game ads are described by finitely
many random matrices
and i want to let the size of matrix go
to infinity and see
what i get
so this is still a very long shot
this has been done
there is something which appear a lot in
the literature which is daison game
in the case of dazzle game z equal to
one
and so that has been done
a lot with d cult one
now d greater than one it is a hope that
something can be done and this is a
this is the motivation
now regarding your second question
what you do is uh
you convert everything you have to the
hilbert space
and on the hillbilly space you use your
you have a notion of convexity
you impose that the convex function you
are dealing with satisfied genesis
inequality
so you can define an
a conditional expectation every time you
have a a trace and you impose that you
are dealing with a
congress function which satisfies just
some inequality and
you replace so cyclic monotonicity is
equivalent to
uh convexity right
and so you have the analog tool so
here's the space formulation
you mentioned that for for any random
variable you know complexly supported
random variable in r you can
come up with these
um
operators to make that the the
corresponding random variable so
if i had some pure state
uh you know some wave function i was
interested in
how would i come up with these operators
to get that to be my
you know would it would would operators
correspond
um could you come up with operators to
correspond to your favorite wave
function
so what you see as an operator is for
instance you take the universal
attraction
right so the inverse laplace i am
working with bounded operator
and one typical operator you can think
about is
the inverse laplacian on the torus for
instance
or you can think about the
multiplication operator the operator
where you multiply everything by
a a function
or you can discretize the inverse
laplacian to get a finite dimensional
operator
so this would be able to give you sort
of a distance between two
wave functions
so it seems to me that your waves
function will be the state right yeah
yeah your wave function whether i am i
am defining distances between the
operator not between the state
i guess i was i was trying to reconcile
with
the way i i always thought of of random
variables quantum random variables which
is like
you know it could be this quantum state
or it could be this other quantum state
basically like a mixed state
i was wondering if there's a parallel
so i can also use some
for instance if you give me an element
of the field space i can construct an
operator from there right the projection
for instance
that would be that would be a very
particular
operator
and
yes maybe from there you can try to
to compare
state because you are associating
operators with them
so maybe one more question
can you say something about like the
dual formulation about these
so let me say something about
how to change
what you
are asking me is that
what you are asking me because the
thermal sum of
s i
square will be independent
of the tau
and so you can show that
this is the supremum
over lambda
naught of f
plus lambda
1 of t
and g
the pointman algebra
and i'm going to impose that ga
of
y
plus fp
of x
are greater than the inner product x1
every
s
and by definition
this
is you can show that it is independent
of a
so you can show that
if i am giving an s bar and y bar set
that lambda naught is wrong
you can show that this is independent of
s of of a and so
data expression makes sense and you
maximize this under this condition which
is like what you do in the
classical
all right
if there are questions
and join me in thanking wilfred again
for that
you